it's michelle from love muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skin care nerd
and today i'm going to be talking about
how to adapt your routine as you get
older
i'm turning 34 this year and i'm
starting to see some changes happen in
my face and if you're around the same
age you'll probably be noticing this as
well
so i'm going to go through some of the
things that you might do to your routine
some things that you might add some
things that you might take away
as you get older if you like talking
nerdy about the science behind beauty
products click the like the subscribe
and the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos
today's video is sponsored by foreo and
i'm going to start by talking about
microcurrent
this topic really highlights one of the
things that i think is really important
when deciding what to use
which is working out exactly what you're
trying to address
when you get older you start to see lots
of changes in your face and a lot of
these don't have
anything to do with skin and so if
you're using skin care products to try
to address these
it's just not going to work one of the
big changes
is sagging and drooping and this is to
do with things
under your skin this is to do with
muscle bone and fat
so you'll start to see a general volume
loss and a shift in the shape of your
face
and unfortunately you can't really fix
this with skincare it's too
deep for skin care to effectively
address to change this you generally
need things like
fillers and surgery facelifts botox
so trying to change this with skin care
just isn't going to work very well if
you see skincare that claims to help
with sagging and drooping
it can help a little bit but skin is
only two millimeters thick so you can
improve that two millimeters but if
everything underneath is still changing
then it's going to be limited i think a
lot of us are pretty uncomfortable with
these sorts of procedures
they're a bit more invasive and i know i
am a complete wuss when it comes to this
sort of thing
so if you're a bit hesitant to go into
this sort of procedural route
then one of the few things that you can
do at home that will actually help is
microcurrent so this
is the ferro bear it is an at-home
microcurrent device
i did a video on how microcurrent works
and how to use the furrowed bear
so check that out if you want more
details microcurrent can make your face
look more lifted
it changes how your muscles tense up and
it can give you the appearance of more
volume
it doesn't seem to have much effect on
fat and bone but it does seem to
increase your muscle volume and
volume is volume you can generally see
the effects pretty immediately so the
most obvious ones are usually in your
cheeks they become more lifted and more
sculpted
and in your forehead as well in general
the effect is going to be more dramatic
if your face is starting to droop a bit
so if you're in your late teens or early
20s then
the effect you're going to see is
probably going to be very limited
but from your mid to late 20s onwards
then you can start to really see that
effect
after just using it once you use it for
only two to three minutes a day
and the effect lasts for a few days so
you do have to keep on using it to
maintain the look
and the more you use it the more that
effect builds up i've seen some people
say that because it's a temporary effect
it's not worth it and i disagree
i think that perspective that something
temporary something that lasts a few
days
isn't worth it comes mostly from people
who don't wear makeup
i think people who use makeup regularly
know that things that are more subtle
things that are temporary can have a big
effect on your appearance
and microcurrent is less temporary than
makeup
and it can have a more dramatic effect
that you can't really get easily with
makeup unless you are super talented
and of course because it goes deeper
than skin care it also does things that
skin care can't
one thing i really like about
microcurrent devices is that you can
pretty much immediately see the sorts of
effects you're going to get
it's not like something in skincare
where you generally have to wait a few
months to see what's happening
whereas microcurrent you can immediately
see what's going to happen
and you know what you're going to get if
you keep on using it with microcurrent
devices it's really important to stick
with it
if you stop using it then the effects
are going to fade and so you have to be
consistent
i really like the furrow there because
i'm not very good at being consistent
with things but this makes it
so much easier it's got a really easy
charging port
or you do a sticker cable in it's a usb
cable it doesn't have like a bulky
charging cradle or anything it also has
this silicone body which makes it really
easy to wipe down and keep clean and
hygienic
when we're talking about the changes
that happen to your skin as you get
older we can split it into two
categories intrinsic and extrinsic
intrinsic changes happen because your
body functions differently as it gets
older and your skin
is part of your body these changes are
largely unavoidable
the main changes we see in skin is that
it gets thinner and more fragile and
you'll start to see
fine wrinkles extrinsic changes happen
because of the environment
the older you are the longer you've been
exposed to the environment
for skin the main environmental thing
that affects us is the sun
and you're probably sick of hearing it
but this is why everyone keeps on saying
to wear sunscreen
the most common changes we see in skin
that's been exposed to a lot of sun
are deep wrinkles and crevices age spots
scaling and dryness in caucasian skin
about
80 of the signs of aging that you see
are because of sun exposure
with darker skin there's melanin which
is protective against uv light
but we still see lots of changes and the
main changes we see are to do with
pigment so this is things like age spots
so unsurprisingly the best way to
prevent these changes
is using sun protection the obvious
thing to use is sunscreen
and you're looking for a sunscreen that
has high uva and uvb protection
both of these contribute to aging and so
you're looking for a broad spectrum high
spf sunscreen that you can happily wear
every day
one study actually found that daily
sunscreen use actually reversed the
signs of aging
and i think this goes to show that your
skin is
living it has the ability to start
repairing itself
as long as you protect it from getting
reattached every day
in general it's a good idea to wear
sunscreen every day when you go outside
if you're worried about these
extrinsic changes in your skin when
you're indoors there's obviously less uv
uvb doesn't penetrate glass but
depending on your situation
you can still get a large amount of uva
if you're close to a sunny window every
day then it is still a good idea to wear
sunscreen
indoors i have a video about working out
whether or not you need to wear
sunscreen indoors and i'll link that in
the description
now when you're in a car i guess you're
technically indoors
but there are windows everywhere so it
is one of the highest exposures you can
get while technically indoors
there's this really famous photo of a
truck driver where one side of his face
was next to a window the other side was
on
the other side facing away from the
closer window and you can really see the
difference when you're really close to a
window
i've had some people ask me about
fluorescent lights fluorescent lights
can produce
tiny amounts of uv and this is
especially the case with compact
fluorescent bulbs these are the windy
looking ones
because of all those curves the coating
inside the light bulb
that usually absorbs the uv sometimes
gets cracked and so little amounts of uv
come
out but it is still a really tiny amount
of uv
so if you're more than 25 centimeters
away from the light
if you're more than about a foot it
takes about eight hours to get the
equivalent of
just over a minute of midday sun
exposure from somewhere like sydney or
melbourne
if you have a plastic diffuser over the
top like you would in a normal office
fluorescent light
then you get even less uv so for the
vast majority of us
that amount of uv isn't worth worrying
about if you have a photosensitizing
condition like some types of lupus
then it could be significant now one of
the problems with sunscreen
is that we tend to get a lot of wrinkles
near our eyes first
but sunscreen near your eyes can really
sting
i've been adding eye sting into my
sunscreen reviews but i found that some
sunscreens that don't sting my eyes will
sting other people's eyes and vice versa
in general alcohol and sunscreens and
chemical sunscreens
tend to sting people's eyes a bit more
one thing i found really helpful is
mineral sunscreen sticks like this one
from neutrogena
sticks tend to run a lot less because
they have a lot more waxes in them
they're a lot more water resistant
and so this can really help if you want
to get sunscreen around your eyes but
you don't want to risk it running into
your eyes
with sunscreen it's important to
remember that it's not just your face
that gets a lot of sun exposure it's
also your neck and your hands
so if you have a sunscreen that doesn't
really work for your face
you can still use it up by putting it on
your neck and your hands
and remember sun protection isn't just
about sunscreen there are other things
you can do as well
so for example avoid going out into the
direct sun for too long in the middle of
the day when there's the most uva and
uvb
you can also use uv protective clothing
like hats and gloves
i actually keep a uv protective cardigan
in the car because
a lot of the time i forget to take it
with me but also when i'm driving i can
slip on the sleeves backwards and then
put my thumbs through the thumb holes
and that protects the backs of my hands
now even if you hide from the sun there
are still those intrinsic changes
even without sun exposure your epidermis
will thin by up to half between the ages
of 30 and 80.
so there are lots of other things you
can use in skincare and the main one is
retinoids retinoids is always what
dermatologists recommend
tretinoin in particular also known as
retinoic acid or retin-a
this is the gold standard ingredient and
there's tons of research to back up its
effectiveness
it can help with fine and coarse
wrinkles roughness freckles and
pigmentation
it can actually make changes to the
lower layers of your skin
so it can increase the growth of skin
cells in your dermis called fibroblasts
and it can increase collagen
so tretinoin is a pharmaceutical it's
usually a prescription only
drug so if you think that might be
suitable for you go talk to a
dermatologist
there are also weaker versions in
cosmetics like retinol and granactive
retinoid and these tend to have less
side effects
if you're introducing a retinoid into
your routine be really careful
go slower than you think you have to if
you use too much too quickly you can
have lots of side effects like dryness
redness irritation and stinging i have
another video on how i personally
introduce tretinoin into my routine
and that will be down below now as your
skin gets older it doesn't hold on to
water as well so it tends to get thinner
and dry out more easily
it also becomes more fragile so it
doesn't stand up to trauma as well and
it doesn't heal as quickly
so you'll have to treat your skin a bit
more gently so things like harsh
physical exfoliants and rough washcloths
probably won't be as suitable
you'll probably want to use less hot
water in your routine as well so hot
water is really good at washing away
the natural moisturizers that your skin
produces you'll probably also want to
use more moisturizer in your routine
and i think a lot of us think of
moisturizer as something that's not very
active
but keeping your skin hydrated is really
important in keeping it functioning
correctly
one of the changes in your skin as you
get older is that your skin doesn't
exfoliate itself as effectively it
doesn't describe
as well part of this is that your skin
turnover decreases you're not producing
skin cells as quickly
but part of it is just dehydration when
your skin is dehydrated then it doesn't
exfoliate itself correctly and so
hydrating it can really help with that
now if your skin still isn't exfoliating
itself enough
then you might want to add in a chemical
exfoliant alpha hydroxy acids are the
chemical exfoliators with the best
evidence for them for anti-aging
they speed up the skin turnover that
slows down as you get older
they also help with other things as well
they can even out pigmentation they can
decrease roughness
and they can even increase collagen
there are different levels that you can
go with with alpha hydroxy acids as well
so something that is a leave on chemical
exfoliant
won't get as deep as a professional peel
one of the issues with alpha hydroxy
acids is that it can
increase uv sensitivity so if you're
using these
make sure you're also using a sunscreen
there are some other anti-aging
ingredients as well
in particular antioxidants vitamin c and
peptides
there is less evidence for these but
they could be worth looking into
depending on your situation
there is a lot of variability when it
comes to the formulas of these though so
a good rule of thumb is to look for
clinical tests on the finished formula
so this is things like before and afters
and clinical studies
now if you're worried about pigment then
one important thing to consider is
the depth of the pigment most skin care
especially if you're not using drug
products
can only really deal with very surface
level pigment
some good ingredients for dealing with
pigment are retinoids hydroquinone
vitamin c butane kojic acid
niacinamide and licorice extract with
extracts be really careful because there
are lots of different types of extracts
and not all
licorice extracts will actually help
with pigment so make sure you look for a
product that actually specifies that
it's full pigment
if you have deeper pigment that these
skincare products aren't really helping
with
or if you're not sure how deep your
pigment is then go to a professional who
can diagnose your problem
and help you out with that so they can
put you on a treatment plan that
includes stronger treatments like
lasers and peels wrinkles come from
repeated movements as well as the
condition of your skin
you can think of it like a piece of
leather wrinkles will form when you fold
that leather repeatedly
this is why you might have heard of
preventative botox that actually stops
your face from moving
as much and so you don't get these
folded in wrinkles there are also
wrinkles called sleep wrinkles that come
from sleeping on your side or on your
front so your face basically gets
smushed up
and because we sleep for about a third
of our lives this smooshing can
etch in a wrinkle in our skin so for a
lot of people it can be worth it to
train yourself to sleep on your back
now some people shouldn't be doing this
because there might be other reasons
they're not sleeping on their back like
sleep apnea
now this is way more serious than sleep
wrinkles and for some people sleeping on
your back just decreases your quality of
sleep so much that it's not worth it it
can also have drawbacks
for people who want to try sleeping on
their back you don't have to have a
special pillow for this although it can
make it a bit more convenient
you can use wedge pillows or you can use
towels to try to keep your head
in one spot you can also try to use a
heavier quilt that sort of holds you in
place
now for makeup i'm still working on
trying to get my concealer to sit
properly
but angie from hot and flashy has tons
of great tips
using a primer underneath your concealer
can really help spread out the concealer
and keep it from shifting into those
lines
and this is a little bit
counter-intuitive but using less
concealer can actually help as well
because then there's less stuff that can
move with things like highlighters it's
good to avoid large particles because
they tend to settle into lines and make
them more obvious
so those are some of my tips for how to
change your routine as you get older
do you have any other tips let me know
in the comments if you liked the video
click the like and the subscribe you can
also follow me on instagram and check
out my blog for more nerdy science
content
thank you to foreign for sponsoring this
video and i will see you next time
you